[Music]
far away
[Music]
what are you doing tonight
not watch stop it
that's gone
all right marquette yes marquette uh
where did you grow up where are you from
originally i was born in bristol
tennessee
and i was raised in minnesota
my family moved to elk river minnesota
when my doc my dad got a job
at control data he was an industrial
engineer
so we moved to elk river
and
i started leaving home and going to
minneapolis when i was in my early teens
you know
i did not come out as gay until i was
over 18
i was always afraid that someone would
find out i was gay
and beat me up
um
i had a hard time because i was feminine
and
i was girly and i have been the target
of violence for my entire life
um and i've been very fortunate that
things haven't been worse
i mean somebody punched me here in the
bottom my teeth came right through my
lip right here
and there's bones in my face got broken
i was in a 20-year relationship in
minneapolis minnesota
to mark simonson
and he fancied himself charles manson
he looked kind of like him
he
i don't know mark had anger a lot of
anger he
he killed the cat and put a hammer
through the aquarium i don't know he's
just trying to get my attention i
couldn't really figure out why he was
always so crazy but i lived in fear
the last 18 years that we were together
you know i never complained and i did
whatever he said because i didn't want
to get hurt
but now
i say something
if people are rude to me they'll hear
about it
i i'm not
able to just turn the other cheek and be
all nice when somebody just cracked oh
god that's the ugliest thing i've ever
seen you know people will actually say
that when they walk by me that's the
ugliest thing i've ever seen
knowing
that i can hear what they're saying
and what's the real ugliness is their
behavior
they are so insensitive they could say
something so cruel
that someone who's already down on their
luck doesn't need another rock thrown in
their face
so
it's hard for you on the street
it was difficult yeah but
i did make some money um
one time in miami
i was picked up by a gentleman who runs
a call service
and he had like five prostitutes working
for him
he left the safe open
and i got a ticket to san francisco
he called my mom trying to get the money
back my mom was laughing her head off i
actually gave him the number to my
parents
it was all an act
i i i would often rip off tricks if if
it was easy to do but
i have given up that life completely not
because i got old
but just because i don't want to abuse
my body the way i did before you know i
want i have more respect for myself
than i have in the past when did you
leave home
about 15 i started leaving home well
that's when i hitchhiked from january
in january
from minneapolis to st petersburg in 49
hours i went straight through and
i couldn't believe i actually did that
today i think back i hitchhike across
the country at 15
i'm like i must have had some balls
something i was i just wanted to get
away so bad i wanted a new life i had a
paper bag and a couple shirts with me
and that was it a dollar 76
kind of like when madonna landed in new
york and she only had 36 dollars except
i never made a record yet
and you uh
you
started supporting yourself how i was a
prostitute when i was a runaway and i i
made fairly good money it was enough to
survive
yeah
when i got kicked out of high school and
the way it happened i kind of am not
happy about the way it ended
i had missed several days okay tim
i was in the principal's office and he
said well you'd be a great student if
you just show up
and i missed another day and the
principal
said get out
and at the time i
i didn't even really care that much
about it i just wanted to go home
and [ __ ]
and do drugs
mark taught me how to shoot up cocaine
and gave me hepatitis b
i've had hepatitis b since i was 17 i
take drugs to keep it in check
i am also
hiv-positive
and i became hiv-positive when i was 17.
so i am 57 now
so i am a long-term survivor i've never
been hospitalized because of the hiv
i take my medicine religiously
and i've been so fortunate you know
god has been looking out for me
because i have done some really put
myself in some really bad situations
just because i wanted drugs
you know i would go out in the night
looking for crack and
it's real dark and you don't know who
you're to meet up
but i was so desperate to get high i
would i would have done practically
anything
once you get started it's so hard to
stop it's like
you just i don't know but
i want everybody to know that i'm
sober today if you don't count marijuana
and it's the greatest thing that i'm off
alcohol and all the hard drugs
and the reason that i'm doing this is
because i love myself
and i want to live
you know i watch
the soft white underbelly and i see all
the different people and their
situations and what happened to them
my conclusion
they could have prevented
a lot of it if they only had loved
themselves i don't think they really
were able to love themselves
so that's why
they put themselves in those bad
situations
it took me a very long time to
appreciate who i am yeah how long you
been clean
uh 15 years good for you
it's great to hear yeah it's great it's
a great life and what do you think
caught i mean were there things in your
childhood that got you into drugs
or kept you kept you using them
yeah um i was abused as a child i may
have mentioned that
my dad was never home and my my mom was
very angry she
beat me with a switch
and then she did something weird she
pushed her breasts into my face when she
was wearing a belly dancing outfit that
she made
and she would push her breasts up in my
face and i felt so uncomfortable see
like incestual
i don't know i was that was weird my my
mom was beat severely as a child so you
know how it goes from generation to
generation it's true
if somebody hits you once
they're going to keep hitting you
and you've got to leave immediately
because
they'll never stop
when mark beat me i oh i can change him
yeah my love is going to cure him of his
anger
nothing could cure him of being the
[ __ ] that he was
no it's not nice to speak ill of the
dead
but since he almost killed me on several
occasions
i think i'll take a pass
once i was sitting at the picnic table
and he threw a seven pound
engine out the window
and it brushed off my face right up like
that if he had gone one inch back see
god was there
if that engine had fallen one inch back
i would be invalid or dead
so he didn't care if he killed me that's
what the message i got when he threw
that engine
he didn't care what happened to me uh
yeah he would beat me over stupid things
just i don't know he he had a lot of
anger for some reason
i met his family nobody could figure out
why he was so mad and
i don't know i stuck with him until his
last dying day
i took care of mark when he had aids i
pushed him around in his wheelchair
helped him get stuff and did whatever i
could
but he became so
weak
that he had to be put into a hospice
this was in san francisco
april 12 2001
i was on a trolley to visit mark
and
he in the hospice
and
all of a sudden when i was on the
trolley
this light came into the trolley
it was moving slow and it was coming
towards me and it had all kinds of
beautiful colors it also had substance
but you could see inside of it and it
was just so incredibly beautiful the
most beautiful thing i ever saw it stood
stood in front of me for like
three to five seconds
and then
it went out the window
i had no idea what had happened i
thought wow what's what's going on i was
kind of in a daze
i got to the hospice where mark was
mark had died
exactly when i saw his soul
mark showed me his soul
if he hurt me he taught me one thing
life never ends it
changes and that's very important to
keep in mind
we are all responsible for our own
behavior
it's it's easy to blame people for
things but when i'm as being sober i can
take
you know if i do something wrong i
apologize about it and try to make it
right but when i was on drugs you know i
wouldn't care if i insulted people or
whatever i had to do to get what i
needed
but you know being sober has made me a
much better person
and much healthier
because of the hiv
you know i had done some meth and that
meth it eats up t cells
and i would get high on meth have wild
you know sex
marathon sex
and then i'd be unable to move for a
week
because that stuff just wiped me out
yeah
i will say that i've never okay one time
i did heroin
i had some guy shot me but he took
almost all of it so i didn't really feel
anything so i really technically have
done heroin but
i have not really done it actually it's
here and there
but what i'm saying is meth to me is
like the worst drug in the world i mean
what's it made from battery acid you
know i'm snorting battery acid to get
high
you know that stuff has things in it
and people know what's in there but they
still want the high so bad
is this the best part of your life right
now
the best part of my life is performing
dancing
i sometimes they call me spinneret
because i spin in spanish but i love to
dance and i love to sing
and every day even though i'm not
attractive and some people say i'm the
ugliest thing that they ever saw
on the outside i might not look all that
terrific
but no
i am smart i'm sensitive i'm caring i'm
loving
it saddens me that nobody at my hotel
can get beyond my outer shell to see who
i am
you know that's what i do every day is i
prove myself to people that i can sing
and i can dance i get people to look
look deeper than just
my skin and to really people can really
see my soul when when i sing you know
i'm very happy when i perform and
um that's probably the only time i am
happy
so you're not living on the street now
no i'm in that i meant the i'm not going
to say the name i'm in a coveted hotel
it's paid for by the state i believe so
technically i'm not homeless but i have
lived in my car for three years
i pride myself in being happy
no matter what
i'm going to be happy
you say something bad about me it's
going out the other ear
i have to i'm kind of training myself
because i know i'm going to hear
negative things about my appearance
because
supposedly i'm so incredibly hideous
but and people say often oh that's the
ugliest thing i've ever seen well i say
to them you're very attractive i tell
them i guess you haven't seen much then
have you
so
i need to tell you about love bug this
is love bug right here lovebug
lovebug is microchipped
he has all his shots
he's been with me for seven years i was
singing on hollywood boulevard and this
woman came up and she tried to take off
lovebugs mask
so i i told her you know get away from
us
she came back again this time she got
the mask off he wears a mask because
sometimes he bites skateboarders
so she came back with two guys and
ripped love bug from my arms and ran
i was being held back by two
20-year-olds i'm 57. i got away
i ran 12 blocks i had 9-1-1 on the phone
i called 9-1-1 when she removed the mask
and then came back a half hour later and
kidnapped love bug
and um
i ran after them i jumped the fence on
hollywood boulevard they were going down
the subway i tried to grab them and they
pushed me off but the hollywood police
who i want to thank with all my heart
they came with their sirens blaring
hollywood and highland where are they
where are they went down the subway so
we all ran down there me and five cops
and two people were arrested
and
[Music]
i want them to know that they did a
hideous thing
you know they thought that i was just
some weak [ __ ] who would let them
take my dog they could walk all over my
life like that
well i don't see it quite that way
love bug is a live breathing it's not
like losing a car or something or having
your jewelry stolen
love bug can't be replaced
and
so even though they threw it out because
i had bad legal counsel
i'm happy it even it made us closer
love but i know
what it would have been like without him
now
you know
so he is with me now
i would do anything for this dog i
turned into super cootie
fighting 20 year olds jumping fences
running from security guards
i didn't know that i was so strong that
i could had that much stamina
but when love bugs life was on the line
something in me
i mean god came into me and made me
i turned into a super cootie for for
several minutes
you know
life
really tests me sometimes
they say that god will never give you
anything that you can't handle
but sometimes
i don't know if that's true
because
so many bad things can happen to you
being a homosexual feminine
semi-transgender
i don't talk and i don't stuff
the people who live at my hotel now they
hate me and want to kill me
so
i have to be happy around people
even though my husband is negative
that's why i left him even though he's
negative i'm going to stay positive
about life
i am going to celebrate what is good in
my life even if it's hard to find
i was watching something and this this
queen was saying
even if you've got only two teeth left
celebrate those two teeth
because
you know appreciate what you've got if
you got it flaunt it what do you uh what
do you regret in your life
i regret that i didn't leave mark the
first time he hit me
because
i think my life would have been
completely different i know excuse me
my life would have been way different he
really held me down
i gave him the best years of my life and
i regret that because i could have been
with somebody who really cared about me
you know
i am so tired of people who pretend to
care and then call me ugly as soon as
they get a chance
you know if if you love someone you
don't treat them like that if you love
is not just a four-letter word
you know it's it's an emotion
that you really can't control
and i loved mark until the day he died
and that's one of the accomplishments i
outlived mark by 20 years
you know he thought i'd be dead and
yeah i do pride myself that i lived 20
years because i thought he was going to
kill me the only way i got out of the
relationship was when he died because i
was too weak at the time to separate but
i never
the doctor had called and told his
brother that mark had a
month to live twice
mean a month to live
he was going to die within a month
so nobody told me that
i thought he was just
sick and he'd get better
and then he just he weighed 83 pounds
when he died
he lost massive amounts of weight it was
it was so incredibly
just sad what what happened to him
[Music]
but when he died and
it was a relief to me
it was a weight off my shoulders
i didn't have to do anything for him
anymore i was free finally free and
could make my own decisions and the
heartache was over
so
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
you ask hard questions
these questions are difficult the most
say that again please what is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life okay the most
important thing that i've learned in my
life
is
to love to to give love
i know now that every good thing i do
actually does come back to me
you know i'll give somebody a little
money
somebody will buy me something to eat
you know it seriously everybody needs to
treat everybody like they want to be
treated you know we all deserve respect
even if we're ugly or fat or maimed
you know we all deserve to be respected
and
amazing things happen
when people
share love
many amazing things in this world you
know this world
can be so cruel
i am a target of violence because i'm
feminine and i have a big mouth
i've been told by gaia my mouth is going
to get me killed
and it's come close i go
one time mark threw a coffee cup from
across the room and landed right here
this one queen i was staying at the
aranda in san francisco i was drunk she
came up put her nails on my face and
ripped
this
i've had a lot of injuries
and i'm still a beautiful person see
that's the thing people might say that's
the ugliest thing i've
ever seen
but anyone who would say that in my
presence knowing i could hear that
that's the ugliness is your behavior
when you disrespect people like that
i was taught manners
and manners to me means
you don't say mean things about people
knowing they can hear it you know
it's torture i i'm told how ugly i am
many many times every day
but i know i'm much more than what i
look like i hope you're all not shallow
i'm not a shallow person anymore
i know
i'm smart
i love to give love i love people
and i love my life
even though there's many problems i
still
am so much better off without
substances okay i do smoke pot
but uh
that's all and i'm so glad to be off all
those
hard
drugs all right thank you so much
marquette i appreciate you coming in and
telling your story all right
you did great
you